let's get stuck the thursday morning
thursday morning session of the speaker
imagine Tony Parker ok so this type will
be based on several papers all very
recent years there are joint works with
our nap eldar puya and sharper and many
of the I'm some of the very nice ideas
that I'm going to mention are from this
first paper where I'm not a Quattro and
if you ever be extended to this general
setting ok so the common theme of these
papers or the common goal of them is to
extend the various nice results about
property testing of graph in graph
theory to this to the more challenging
setting of algebraic properties where we
work with abelian groups or F P to the N
and in that setting so we all know what
property testing is it's you're given a
function it can be a graph for example
can think of a graph as a function we
are allowed to only draw very small
samples from dysfunction so which can
evaluate then very few number of points
and by just looking at those few points
we want to distinguish two cases the
case where the function satisfies the
given property for example a graph is
triangle free from the case where it's
far from satisfying the property so we
want to satisfy to distinguish the green
area from the white area and we don't
care about this gray area where the
function is doesn't satisfy the property
but it can be much it's very close to
some function which satisfies the
property so we can ignore just this area
now so the reason I got into this area
was that they've been using tools like
higher order for analysis and regularity
lemma that I was interested in so I'm
not to expert in this area so I might
offend some people because I don't know
the history that's awesome even some
dead people as a fan I was saying but as
to the best of my knowledge this area
kind of emerged from this work on
linearity test by blom doobie and run it
and some other papers by way Portman I
learned that area but there are all the
results like Regis Emiratis triangle
removal mr this result of Garuda roudram
Duke from 85 that they had the same
spirit there in the same spirit so you
can just express them in the language of
property testing but the whole area or
this whole notion of property testing is
formally defined in mid 90s or these two
papers ripping fit suit Sudan and gold
rock go buzzer and run and it's as I
said it's very closely related to
regularity which also makes it kind of
very related to the these notions of
limit ira's of combinatorial objects
where you draw samples from the objects
and you define some kind of convergence
no show okay so let's go to our setting
so by algebraic setting I'm in the
following so I'm interested now my
functions are functions from FP to the N
to some finite sets 02 are here p is a
fixed prime and r is a fixed integer so
all the asymptotics are as n goes to
infinity so my domain grows by growing
the value of n not p or are two
important cases where I care about are
the case where r is equal to 1 then in
this case we've been we are talking
about bullying valued functions and the
other interesting case is where r is
equal to P minus 1 and then I can talk
about all functions from FP to the M to
FP by identifying this set with FP so I
can talk about polynomials understand
the functions / FP now I was talking
about being far from a property so we
should have a notion of distance and
that distance is defined by just it's a
point wise distance I mean the distance
between two function is the fractional
points where they differ so f is
different from g
and then once i define the distance
between two functions i can define the
distance from a function to a property
and that's just the distance from F to
the closest function that satisfies the
property and for testing mode in most of
the stock I'm going to talk about this
particular notion of property testing
which is sometimes referred us to
proximity oblivious testing which means
that my number of queries is just a
fixed constant it's like five ten or
whatever I'm not allowed to change it
according to my parameters so given a
function f I'm allowed to make this
constant number of queries and I want to
distinguish between two cases so if F
satisfies the property I I always want
to accept it so I don't allow error here
but if F is far from the property so if
F is epsilon far from the property then
I want the probability of rejection to
be bounded away from zero so this will
be some delta which depends on epsilon
but not on f okay and the number of
queries doesn't depend on epsilon so for
every epsilon with justice fixed number
of queries I want to reject with the
probability which is bounded away from
zero so you can see in this picture if
the function satisfies the property I
always want to accept it if it's epsilon
far I want to reject it with this
probability which is bounded away from
zero so let's look at the simplest
possible example my property is just
being identically zero so I'm interested
in testing whether function is
identically zero so what is the natural
test I just need to pick one point so I
pick one random point X I accept a
function if it's zero on that point and
I reject it otherwise so why is this
valid test or valid proximity oblivious
test it has just one query so it
satisfies the constant number of queries
also if the function is zero I'll always
accept it there is no way I see
something non zero here and if the
distance is at least epsilon it means
that my function is 1 and at least
epsilon fractional points then there is
epsilon probability that i'll pick one
of those points so the probability of
reject will be at least epsilon so the
probability at least epsilon which is it
just depends on epsilon and spam the way
from zero I detect one of these points
where my value is 1 okay so in this
algebraic setting if I just look at a
generic property I'm not using anything
about this algebraic structure of FP to
the M so we should impose some
conditions on p we don't want to treat
FP to the n as some just generic set of
size P to the N and it turns out that
there's a natural and also the right
kind of condition the important that's
that the properties are finding variant
and so watch it and this is suggested by
colleague of mine on my the Sudan which
so the conditions that we call the
property a fine invariant if it's closed
under affine transformation so whenever
my function satisfies the property then
if I composed with and with an affine
transformation which is just a linear
transformation plus some ship then it
still has to satisfy the property so a
very important example of these
properties are set a polynomial so if
you have bounded degree degree bounded
by some constant T so if you take this
polynomial and compose it with an affine
transformation it cannot increase the
degree so it will remain in this set ok
so the question is which I find
invariant properties are testable so
let's look at the polynomial example so
this set has an interesting property and
that is this can be characterized
locally and that means that a function
has degree at most if and only if all
its restrictions I find subspaces of
dimension D plus 1 also are of degree at
most D so to check whether a polynomial
is a degree at most D you only need to
check it in this local wait look at all
the affiance of spaces so these are just
sets of constant size
sighs p to the D plus 1 and check
whether if you restrict to them you'll
see a polynomial of degree at most D so
one direction is obvious the other is
again easy but not obvious so if the
Paula if F has degree at most D then of
course any restriction it to any
affiance of space not even this
dimension will have degree at masti but
the opposite is interesting direction so
this suggests the test which is not a
priori clear that it's valid test that
we just pick a random subspace a fine
subspace V and look at the restriction
of F to be if it's at most evil say that
except a function if it's not then we
reject so again we have to why is this a
valid test one direction is obvious if
the function is of degree at most D then
will always accept it because
restricting does not increase the degree
but the interesting case which is which
needs work is that if the distance if my
function is far from being a polynomial
of degree D then there are many such
subspaces where the function fails to
have degree at most even your restrict
so when we sample the subspace at random
good probability will hit one of these
subspaces will which will detect that
the function is a degree in larger than
D ok so let's look at this general
setting now not just degree all locally
characterized abode properties so we say
that the property is locally
characterized abow if it's characterized
by just looking at restrictions of some
constant dimensional a fine subspace
constant I measure my applying subspaces
so there exist some cases that we have
this condition that if you check if our
restrictions of vf2 subspaces of
dimension at most k satisfy the property
then if satisfies the property now we
can just try to do the same test and our
main the main result of this paper which
starts with BF h and ends with l is that
all locally care
try zabal properties are testable so
it's kind of generalization it a very
powerful generalization of this testing
of polynomials and in this setting that
proximity oblivious that number of
queries will be constant and the test is
of course natural just we pick this
random subspace and check it so I'm
going to just sketch a very high level
of the proof basically mentioned some
ideas in the proof so for that I'm going
to go to something very basic which is
triangle I'll start from this very basic
example which is kind of the first maybe
interesting property testing which has
the ideas of regularity so let's all
recall the proper the property testing
for triangles freeness so what is the
test just pick three random purchases
and see if they form a triangle if they
form then we say that no it doesn't it's
not triangle Korean otherwise we'll exit
and again the two directions when it's
trivial if the graph is triangle free
will always accept and then there is
this non-trivial direction so how do you
one of those one prove this direction
it's very close I mean it's basically
the same thing as the triangle removal
Emma so how does the proof of that go so
we start from a graph G which we know
it's far from being triangle free we
want to say that our test rejects it
with some large problems so do we
proceed from here we regularize the
graph so we put using similarities
regularity lemma we partition it into
many parts so most so this is kind of
adjacency matrix of GV partition vs.
into many parts and we know that most
cells will be uniform except some
epsilon fraction of them and those will
be non-uniform so then there is a clean
up stage where we we remove all these
irregular parts so we remove all the
edges which are inside the irregular
parts also we remove the edges from the
cells which are almost empty so if there
is a cell which uniform but they're very
few edges we also clean up that
remove all the edges from them now why
is this good now so the new graph is
close to the old graph and we knew that
this one is far from being triangle free
so we know that this new from that we
conclude that the new graph also
contains some trackers because it's
close to G so H this new graph the
scholars edge has a triangle and from
that because it's very structured than
all these things are uniform and they're
on there are many edges in this non
empty cells we conclude that it has many
triangles and that just gives us the
original graph also had many triangles
because we only remove the edges from G
so that can't couldn't create any new
trial so this kind of how one uses
regularity to prove it property testing
in the most obvious case now let's look
at something more interesting which is
now I look at the property of not
containing a cycle of length 5 as an
induced sub graph so now here there are
also non edges that I care about I don't
want to have ages between certain
vertices so the test is again natural
just pick foreign purchases and see what
happens on those five vertices and so
again we want to show that if my graph
is far from being induced e53 then I'll
detect there many in Dulce fives in
there so I'll detect them when I test
with these five words now if you look at
just a previous proof and try to just
replace triangle with c5 we have a
problem that is in this cleanup stage
when we remove these edges from these
cells we might create new cycles of
length 5 induce cycles of length 5 so
when we remove these things this might
create some new cycles of length 5 so
the fact that this new graph contains
many induced see files doesn't imply
that the old graph also contains many
suffice and so this proof fails but to
overcome this Allen Fisher creepy
leverage and SEGA d they proved some
variant of regularity lemma which suited
for this purpose and in the regular in
their regularity lemma they have two
partitions so one has this original
partition which is denoted here by this
orange lines and then there is another
finer partition which refines the
original one so the two a and B now also
for every part in the or in the course
partition we pick one representative sub
part so for example here I picked this
first one within this second one and so
on now the they show that one can do
this in a way that now if you look at
these green cells which are just between
these sub cells they're all uniform
there are no exceptions so all of these
pairs are uniform and that most of the
lecture you represented the bigger cell
that contain them so if you look at any
of these B cells but most of them they
have the same then almost the same
density as the sub cell inside them now
why is this good so there is a way of
just modifying now this big graph using
this small cells or it is representative
cells such that if you find something in
the big graph after modification you can
just look at these small ones and
they're very uniform so you can find
many copies in the original graph so
I'll talk a bit more about it in this
setting which I'm interested the
algebraic setting so remember we wanted
to prove that every locally
characterized well property is testable
so the general steps are the same as
well as the graph case so we start from
a function which is far from being far
from satisfying the property so there's
epsilon distance to pee now we
regularize it so we partition it so that
in a nice way we can end up things by
just looking at this partition and then
we modify the graph for this cleanup
stage where the change things to f only
small modification and we obtain a new
function g which is close to f
and because G is close to F it will not
satisfy the property and so it should
violate some local constraint and these
local constraints and the fact that you
had this nice property one can use it to
show that F also should violate many
copies of that local property so the
test should work that's the general
thing so the first step is
regularization as I mentioned now
instead of graph we have this function
over F P to the N and we want to
decompose it in a nice way so that F is
uniform on most part so how does the
partition work here so here we are more
restricted because we're looking at this
I fine restrictions and we want to
preserve those kind of distributions so
we should partition them according to
polynomials I find invariant yes and to
just zero to R yeah now the partition is
going to be defined by polynomial so I
have if I have constant number of
polynomials q1 to QC from FP to the n to
FP all of degree at most D then I can
partition my group or my vector space
according to these polynomials in the
following way I'm just going to look at
the values of these polynomials and this
is just a vector in FP to the sea which
is just a finite set of constant site
sighs in fact or sees the cancer and
decide according to this were so kind of
induces a partition on the whole space
and according to these values so if you
have quadratic functions we will see
this quadratic structures and so on now
okay so that's the partition and has
this properties that if you take the
large enough it's possible to do so so
that we keep the same distributions when
you do approximations with these kind of
partitions now now the usual regularity
again has this problem that the same
problem that
sub and we worked with induced e5 so we
need to prove something similar to this
regularity of Allen Fisher Grigorievich
and SEGA d and this algebraic setting so
that's the main challenge so we need two
partitions again so the first partition
will be defined by some polynomial P 1 2
p.a I want to refine it to get a second
partition so the natural way to refine
it is just add more polynomials so I'm
going to add more polynomials q1 to q2
this and that will give me the second
Sigma algebra or the finer partition yes
so every set of polynomials defines
partition so I have two partitions one
defined by this this there is a bound on
the degree now then it's not the same
degree so so all of them are bounded the
degrees are all bounded by some constant
which comes from the the dimension of
the vector spaces at the local
characterization hey so the now I want
to find sub cells that represented the
bigger cells so so let's look at for
example this atom of the disk or Sigma
algebra i want to pick some sub at home
which represents it so it has the same
densities with good probability and also
it's uniform I turns out so one of the
nice ideas which is kind of a core idea
which was from this first paper that I'm
not a Quattro i mentioned way arnab
elderon shahar is that all these sub
cells should be picked by just a fixed
vector so i'm going to pick a fixed
vector c 0 and for each one of these
atoms in the course Sigma algebra I'm
going to look at the sub atom which
corresponds to setting q12 QB to this
fixed vector so I can't just do this
arbitrarily you just pick one cell here
from here so that the densities are the
same so it's really important that all
of them come from
aim chosen by the same representative
vector so why is this important because
we are after this doing this cleanup
will find some a fine structure in this
course sir Sigma algebra so something in
this partition something here something
here and so on but we want to be able to
find the same thing in this sub cells
because sub cells are the ones that we
know they are all uniform it's a the
fact that's finding something in this
big kiss in this course Sigma algebra
also implies that you can find the same
thing in this fine small sub cells
follows from this fact that we made sure
that all of them are represented by the
same vector okay so what is the cleanup
stage this is the same as a graph case
so we want to remove all the
irregularities and unpopular values so
the way it works is that for each one of
these small atoms we denote by TC the
most popular value there so there are
different values there and with TC is
the one which which appears there most
often so and the modification is that if
there is a regular cell in the big in
the course Sigma algebra we just set
every there everything there to this
popular value and also if there is if
there is an unpopular value in these
small cells I'm going to set it again to
TC to something popular so this first
one is like in triangle removal emma is
like removing all these irregular cells
and the second one is like emptying this
the atoms which were had very few edges
so those same two things
no but the popular values from the small
sub cell right yeah everythings that's
just but this new function that I
obtained is close to the original
function so it's not in P and so I'll
find some I find some space such that if
I restrict my function to that it will
violate the condition so this affine
subspace would be something here in this
course so and then I can just find many
of those by looking at this small green
cells so if you have many copies of ww
that will violate the condition so
that's how the proof goes outline of the
proof so actually the main contribution
in this paper that I had that the second
one is we so all these ideas were in the
original paper but we needed some kind
of akwa distribution theorem for these
polynomials for small values of P so
I'll tell you in a second what that
means so how does the proof go we
approximated f by looking at this
partition so we are approximating f by a
function we just looked at the values of
these polynomials which correspond to
the partition right yes so I yeah
exactly yes how how to work with this I
mean it wasn't even clear why this
polynomial partitions are useful why we
are working with polynomials right ah
regular no no so you've been regular
okay I'll tell you what it is so we do
this partition and it's like by doing
using this gallery storms and uniformity
we know that this approximation works
but then i'm going to select i'm going
to look at these restrictions of F to
find subspaces so I want to analyze this
thing I already know that instead of app
I can do it with this camera but how do
i how do you analyze restrictions of
this gamma two subspaces so that's what
I want to say that there you need it's
kind of akwa distribution so I'm picking
this up on subspace V and K dimensional
so let's denote its point by L 12 LP to
the K cancer number of points now well
i'm looking at gamma applied to this
queue of these points so basically i'm
applying gamma to the rows of this
matrix q1 of l12 QC of l1 and so on and
i want to analyze this so to be able to
do that I need to understand the
distribution of this matrix for these
polynomials that define my partition
matrix so green towel for large values
of P and then Italian shahar for small
values of P they showed that if this
polynomial satisfies the some condition
which call like high rank condition
which i'm not going to define then if
you pick a random xq1 to QC of x will be
almost independent and so we just also
corresponds to the fact that this
partition will be almost an equal
partition so what does that tell us
about it distribution of this matrix it
tells us that all rows are almost if you
restrict to a row the entries are almost
independent but that's not enough for
our purpose right we want to understand
the Joint Distribution of this make
entries of this matrix and we can't
expect to have this kind of independence
and the reason is that there are some
restrictions which come or dependencies
that come from degree condition for
example if you have a polynomial of
degree 1 then it always satisfies this
condition that if you have four points
which l1 plus l2 is a 3 plus L 4 then
this identity hold so the value of Q l4
will be determined by the value of these
three other points so there are some
dependencies they're coming from these
degrees and what one wants also it's not
just degree one right can go to degree 2
then you can take discrete derivative so
you get some identity on eight points
and so on so what one wants to prove is
that these are the only dependences if
the polynomials are a high rank then the
only dependence is that you see are the
ones that coming from just this degree
conditions up to some small error of
course and that's what which are we did
it for large values of P and then in
this paper for a small values of P so
when you go to small values of P you
have to replace actually polynomials by
some non classical polynomials which are
not so nice to work with and but we can
prove such a statement but we had it
works for a fine systems of linear
phones which was what we needed here and
more recently we got through the DISA
fine condition too so we have just just
the general case where you have some
systems of linear forms and you want to
understand you're saying that if this
polynomial Tsar of high ranked and we
understand all the dependencies this is
really a basic thing and not just for
property testing if you work if you want
to work with these things and do higher
order for analysis that's really what
you need to be able to it's kind of like
understanding how characters work when
you apply them to linear structures
thank me is high it means that any
linear combination of them so it's a
polynomial you can't write it as a
function of few polynomials of lower
degree so a quadrant high rank quadratic
is a function a quadratic polynomial
which you can write it as a function of
fuel in ears and so on so it kind of
generalized so in some sense means is
there generic polymers okay and okay the
next thing I want to talk about is that
so what are the other examples of
locally characterized about properties
or other natural examples so one example
that we saw before was just a set of
polynomials of degree at most D we can
generalize this to something which we
call degree structural properties so in
now I have a degree sequence d1 to DC
and my function satisfies the property
if it can be written as in this form
some gamma of p1 to PC where gamma is
also fixed and these polynomials are of
degree at most D I so if C is 1 and
gamma is just the identity function i'm
going to get this polynomial says i can
get more interesting sets for example
the property of being the product of two
quadratic polynomial or the property of
being a square of a quadratic polynomial
or the property that my function can be
expressed in this form a B plus C D
where a b c and d are cubic polynomials
and be sure that every degree structural
property is locally characterized abul
so if you look at any of these sets it
has a characterization that your
function is in the set if and only if
restriction it to some fixed finite the
all restrictions of it to some finite
dimensional sub fine subspaces are have
the property actually surprisingly or
annoyingly our proof uses regularity we
approximate if this thing and then we go
from there and because of this we really
get really don't get any bounds on the
dimension so if you look at these
properties that i have here using our
proof you don't really know what this k
is you get some kind
inverse Ackermann type of bounds for the
dimension that you need to look at so
it's it's really desirable I think to
find a direct proof which doesn't go
through regularity and think dependency
on P Ewing I don't know we consider the
constant know now we haven't taught that
man Tatsuya service but yeah don't know
yet degree was the one so need to take
up so the notion of testing that I was
talking so far was this proximity a blue
oblivious where I just allowed constant
number of queries but a more general
notion which is very interesting is now
I I can allow number of queries to
depend on this epsilon so it's same as
above so I want to accept a function if
it satisfies the property so it has this
one-sided error thing doesn't allow
error here and reject the same thing as
before but now number of queries can
depend on epsilon and also look at
two-sided error regime where you also
allow to make errors here with some
probability and one of the beautiful
results in this area is this result of
Alan Shapiro that every hereditary grab
property is testable in this setting so
hereditary graph property means that its
cause undertaking induced subgraphs so
if you restrict your graph to any number
of vertices then if it original one
satisfies the property the sub graph
also should satisfy the induced sub
graph for example bipartite nurse has
this property and so let's try to see if
we can come up with something similar in
this pan invariant properties we call it
well the natural hair is eternity
there is to restrict to a fine subspaces
right we're working with sampling a fine
subspaces so we call the property I find
hair the tree if it's if a function
satisfies it then all any restriction of
it to any affine substrate should
satisfied like the degree at most D case
is an example of a fine invariant
hereditary property here and there's
this conjecture to earn a bigger school
and Shapira that basically just the same
conjecture the same statement for graphs
stated in this side in this setting that
every effin subspace hereditary property
is testable with one sided air now well
what we proved is that if you again I
can't really be precise here if your
property has this bounded complexity
condition and here bounded complexity is
something which studied by Julia by a
garrison wolf that your your
distribution is controlled by some
garish norm so you can do these
approximations your function with some
partition defined by polynomials of just
some bounded degree so that maximum
degree that you can put there is called
the complexity of your property so what
we proved is that if you have if your
property has that bound this complexity
condition then you're testable so in
particular locally characterized of all
functions have that balanced complexity
but yeah I'm kind of I'm not sure if I
believe this conjecture because if you
don't have this condition then it means
that you can't really I don't see any
way of working with this kind of
regularity and approximating your
function with something that works with
your distribution so we all know that
for example 3 time I'd matic
progressions you can prove x mi the
serum for 3 time at my progressions you
can prove it using triangle removal
imap4 term using hyper graph for 300 for
my programs and so on so
this one to one kind of correspondence
between what you can prove in this
algebraic setting and the hypergraph
case and if you don't have this bounded
complexity it kind of means that you
have to work with general hypergraphs
with no uniformity condition and it's
hard for me to believe that you this
statement might be true although I mean
my piece for some reason that I can't
think of it true but also I can't
construct any country example get no
that's another thing it's very hard to
even construct things which are not a
bounded complexity like even random you
can contact him randomly but yes is the
linear system that corresponds to Gomez
conjecture so I don't know whether that
can be translated into
so that seems to be a home okay yeah so
that's a very good coping problem i
think probably the most interesting one
so just mention the remaining time just
one more result that suppose you have a
property p and some costs and nonzero
constant now think of don't think about
us something very small can be like
one-third or something then p sub alpha
is the setup function with distance at
most alpha so you kind of make this
property fat by looking at everything
which is in distance at most alpha
there's a result due to fisher Newman
from 2007 that says that if a graph
property is testable then this P alpha
is testable for any Alpha with two sided
there so what does this mean it means
that you can estimate the distance from
a testable property and we prove the
same thing for a finding very property
so if it's testable then you can test on
this yeah so testing p alpha kind of
corresponds to seeing whether the
distance is at most out for nasa and
estimated the same and this was unknown
even before this even for simple case
such as cubic polynomials what is it can
you estimate the distance of a function
to a cubic so let me just tell you what
the test is without giving the proof
suppose i have a function f i want to
estimate its distance to a given
property i'm going to pick a huge a fine
random i find subspace so it's of
constant dimension by this discussion is
going to be something very large and
then will the test I mean the fact that
test works is that we can show that then
the distance of F restricted to W from
the property is
good approximation of distance of the
original function from the property so
this doesn't hold for any all properties
it holds for testable properties so it
has two parts where if f is up a close
then fw can't be very far and if f is
far then if restricted to w can't be
very close to be so i'm going to skip
this and instead go and talk about often
problems so i mean as i said the main
for me the most interesting problem here
is it is every affine invariance i find
some specific to property testable this
conjecture of upgrade school and Shapira
and another open problem that they've
already mentioned was that finding a
direct proof that without using
regularity that degree structural
properties are locally characterized
able which hopefully will give some
reasonable bounds and the other problem
which have something that have been
thinking about on enough from my PhD
time is that suppose you have a function
from ft t DN 2 f2 then we know that so
for those of you who know what is
uniformity norms are that using garrus
you for norm you can distinguish these
two things whether your function has
correlation with a nonclassical
polynomial of degree 3 or that its
correlation is very small so if you if
you can estimate you for norm then you
can estimate a correlation of the
function with these non classical
polynomials cubix using I mean it
follows from the inverse theorem for
these so this is not exactly the testing
setting that we had before because the
inverse theorem says it's a very crude
estimate if you know you for norm you
know that your correlations between this
and that so but the interesting things
that is this has
16 queries just this if you write the
you for known and the interesting
question I think is that can you find a
test for cubic polynomial so can you
make some number of constant number of
queries and distinguish between the case
that your function has negligible
correlation with cubic polynomials or
some large correlation with cubic
polynomials so they the you for this is
the natural test which people use for
cubic and it fails here because of these
counter examples to the original inverse
theorem yes your number of queries is
constant right there it depends on
epsilon which the main result that
locally characterized book no but but
here I'm not interested in seeing
whether I'm cubic or far from cubic
right here is the correlation it's not
so it's like distance half and distance
half plus something so the only things
are that we know are the things come
from garish norms so they provide such a
test for something right the coil
through inverse theorems that if garish
norm is large you correlate with
something and if it's small you don't
correlated that so the basically the
question is is there such a test or such
a normal system sets of systems of
linear form which provides something
similar for cubic polymers and
just a quick clarification you eat
you're proposing to replace in our
classical cubits with cubics yes but
then you for gnome doesn't work yes this
is my next okay you something to hoist
the cup case look like a jerk like a
sleeping like the graft cases like the
hypergraph face in terms of the stones
of the result that you make it's more
like hypergraph case oh yes yeah i just
started with graphic as the simpler to
no no that's yes I don't yeah so small
complicated regular is more complicated
box they don't need the full power
Yeah right the problem with this is that
a look at when you go to work in this
algebraic setting the inverse theorems
don't have any good bounce so there's
really no I mean that I guess the the
point of those things is that they
provide better balance here like so does
the one the main point of the world but
in some sense it all it says is that you
really need a weaker notion of
regularity in order for these properties
but it does give you a better bottom but
refer that but it also works it it gets
a better moment because it works with a
bigger version not the football I'd say
what you're using is actually already
quite a week notion of regularity there
because we don't understand regularity
in the algebraic setting well enough to
have these really strong quantitative
beyond the quadratic
further questions
it's working on others
anything about I mean yeah I mean there
is also the just z NK straight at the
site cyclic group which i am herbert and
stare it's the partitions are even more
complicated you need to work with these
new sequences